I'm going to have tell like
everyone I meet that I'm just
holding it for my
girlfriend...who doesn't exist.
(jazzy music)
- [male voice] A week ago, to
help with video production,
I got a fanny pack, so I figure
this is just a slippery slope.
- There's a very fine
line between feminine
purses and man bags, so whatever.
- I feel like I'm going to leave it
somewhere and lose all my shit.
- And I'm expecting that
I might get locked out.
- I'm actually excited.
I'll finally have a place
to put my sunscreen.
- [male voice] This is my color for sure,
but it's also a bright green purse.
- This one's more of a winter.
What do you think would look good with me?
- [male voice] This one
would be a statement piece.
- [male voice] Maybe I should be different
and just get this one.
- If you're going to do something in life,
you got to go big, so I'm
going to take the red purse.
- This seems the neutralist
of the bunch, so I'm going to
be a wimp and go for this one I think.
- I can never find anything in here.
- [male voice] This is awesome.
It feels like Hanukkah or something.
- I have my wallet.
- I've got the giant iPhone.
- Miscellaneous gum wrapper.
- I'll be I'm the only person
doing this where the first
thing they put in is a knife.
- - [male voice] Can I fit
this in here? Oh, I can.
- A week from now, I
expect to have a full-on
rain poncho in here.
- I actually think I might
be able to handle this.
- [male voice] So it's been
like five minutes since
I got the purse and I've
already put my phone
in my pocket twice.
- I actually got a lot
of compliments on this.
- Chris is working the purse.
- Thank you.
- I can't even tell it's a purse.
- The key to rocking a purse in public,
you got to rock the walk.
- That was highly disappointing.
I don't think she--
She either didn't notice
my purse or it's just like,
I don't care.
- [Voiceover] This is
not her first man purse.
- Yeah, this is not her first time.
- Audrey, why did you laugh
at me earlier today in class?
- Because of your purse (laughing).
- So I am doing laundry and
as soon as I get in here,
there's this gorgeous girl
in a bikini top and just
being super nice and hi and friendly and
I immediately go to hide it.
- That's right world, I'm
riding a scooter with a
fashionable handbag.
Deal with it!
- When I was at home, my
mom asked me specifically
to not bring my purse
with me because, you know,
she was concerned that I
was going to be made fun of.
You know, In Hollywood, most
people really don't care.
I think in other parts of
the world, this experiment
wouldn't even be able to
happen because there would
just be way too much ridicule
that nobody would want
to do it, you know.
- [male voice] Let's un-bag.
- My keys, my wallet, and my phone.
- This is such a great
place to keep your receipts.
- Vick's Vapor Rub.
- I have three USB chargers.
- Uh, hello, a change of clothes.
I can carry this around
with me in case I need
to change t-shirts.
- I've never carried
hand lotion in my life.
- Some lipstick (smacks lips),
I mean chapstick, oh gosh.
- Guys don't have a
socially acceptable place
to keep your condom.
- And a copy of 1988's Big with Tom Hanks.
- And if your'e like me,
you'll get one that's actually
a garden gnome with a
pornographically long...member.
- [male voice] A week of
wearing a purse was a little
easier than I was hoping it to be.
- It helped me be organized in that I know
where each of my essentials are.
- I think I got like a
couple of jolly smiles when I
would be purchasing stuff.
- But I never fully lost
the self-consciousness
of having a purse on me.
- I don't think I'd ever do it daily.
- After this, I'm actually
considering switching over
to a bag of this size.
- That is the benefit of the purse.
All this I get to carry around with me,
and I need all this stuff.
- I'm amazed at how
strong the gender bias is.
- How crazy of an idea is
that if we just called it
the bag that everyone gets to wear.
- If you want to carry a purse, do it.
If you want to carry a man
bag or a satchel, do that.
It's great, but please just
let me use my pockets again.
- [male voice] My girlfriend
was like, oh my god,
whose purse is that?
And I was like, oh, I'm doing
this for a Buzz Feed video
and I explained what it is.
And she was like, oh my god, thank god.
I thought you got me a really tacky purse.
And I was like, I picked this out.